this is a production of Cornell
University
so if everybody hear me okay good so one
thing I learned about having goats they
give you plenty of opportunity to talk
about things to talk about in a seminar
that's entertaining so so I'm going to
talk to you a little bit about the
personal and societal perspectives of
Agriculture it's not just about growing
food everybody here is familiar with
growing food so I want to talk to you
about some of my personal experiences
our family's personal experiences on the
farm I'm gonna talk a little about the
historical parts how other cultures
treat agriculture and natural resources
our family a little bit on nutrition and
I'm going to close off with the effects
that I felt from climate change on our
farm and some of the spectroscopy areas
that we need to consider for for
adaptation practices
okay now how do I start no I need just
there's a there's a video imagine the
earth as an athlete if it were sliced
into four pieces three pieces would
represent the Earth's if the remaining
piece was sliced in half again one piece
would represent the land on earth that
is unsuitable or inhospitable for farm
this leaves one-eighth the people
representing land grow food
three-quarters of the remaining apple
slice would represent soils too poor to
produce food or land covered by cities
roads and buildings remaining piece 1/32
of the Apple represents the portion of
the earth where food this is our
farmland the thin peel of this slice
represents the farmlands layer of
topsoil where the United States this is
about an acre of farm over 70% of
america's fruit vegetables and dairy
products are produced on farms near
cities that lie directly in the path of
sprawling development sustainable
practices and careful planning such as
farmland conservation are needed to
protect this precious resource for today
and for the future okay so these are my
two children they're much older than
this now mikey is now 270 pounds Alice
almost as tall as I am she's centre of
our basketball team so but when I was
their age maybe a little bit older the
one thing I always wanted was have a
farm
you know it's just something in 16 years
ago my wife and I we got that
opportunity so we bought a hundred and
two acre farm just south of Danby and
then the house wasn't habitable so we
had to rebuild the house and when that
finished we started farming the property
and so we have chickens and eggs we used
to have goats a lot of cats but I
learned a lot
you know from agriculture and how it
helps me at Cornell running the lab when
I first came to the farm I talked to my
neighbor who was farming it and his
comment to me was that Cornell wasn't
useful tool much anymore and so when I
got the opportunity to come back to
crocosaurus I was at the USDA at the
time to direct the lab I decided I was
going to change that I wanted our lab to
be useful to actu farmers again and so
my experiences on the farm helped me to
develop new methods because the methods
are in place except for the soil testing
was we were able to tell them what went
wrong after it happened and as a farmer
you want to know what do I need to do to
prevent it from happening in the first
place so we started developing methods
for that this is I guess a slot or what
we have in our soil health program and
if they quote from Thomas Jefferson he
writes well the farmer holds the title
to the land actually belongs to all the
people because civilization itself rests
upon the soil and sometimes you farm it
you begin to appreciate the importance
of soil and agriculture and what happens
if we lose it
why is it important I've come to believe
agriculture is important to us not only
as a food source but as a familiar
experience accessible to everyone that
can help that it can help us understand
many aspects of life nature in science
agriculture is a practice so rooted in
reality that it can guide our decisions
so I in you know in this growing up this
millennial age I guess we sometimes
think we're sort of the center of the
universe everything is right there for
us whatever we want we just turn it on
we'd want this news cable now where we
just switch the channel and everything's
there for us you realize that when
you're farming your life is guided by
nature and what's around you when you
have to make decisions based on that you
quickly learn that you're not the center
of the universe anymore referring for
this presentation I realized our country
was founded not by lawyers but by a
bunch of farmers so if I don't go back
to the history of our country and that's
why I say maybe that's the reason it
succeeded he understood the laws of
nature that guided their decisions so
here's a section taken out of the
Declaration of Independence the wording
is kind of hard from back then but I'll
read it when in the course of human
events it becomes necessary for one
people to dissolve their political bands
which have connected them with another
and to assume among the powers of the
earth the separate and equal station to
which the laws of nature and of nature's
God entitle them a decent respect to the
opinions of mankind requires that they
should declare the causes which impel
them to separate essentially what they
probably from agriculture and
understanding the laws of nature they
knew that the laws of nature and nature
God gave them the right to become an
independent nation that contributed to
our forming an independent country so
I'm going to talk a little bit about how
they felt about agriculture
anta booth wrote that the founding
fathers believed that the first
President of the United States George
Washington John Adams Thomas Jefferson
and James Madison were revolutionary
farmers as much as they were
revolutionary politicians they loved
farming and gardening so much that they
gave that permanence even when engaged
in war in politics
gardening or farming was central to
their lives and they were and they were
truly the first environmentalists they
believed independent small-scale farms
whoops let me go back I'm gonna
highlight that they believed independent
small-scale farms are the building
blocks of the nation and one thing I
became concerned about when I had a farm
is that we're losing all of our small
farms to industrial farming and we need
to find ways to go to go back to having
more small-scale farms we got to put
things in balance and if affrights
that Jefferson believed that agriculture
should be the foundation of American
Republic rather than industry that he
put more importance to to agriculture
than to industry George Washington
studied and implemented improved farming
methods throughout his life in fact he
thought of himself first
as a farmer Washington read the latest
works on agriculture and implemented the
new husbandry methods using a variety of
fertilization methods in crop rotation
plans on his five farms interviews with
the National Republic radio and Ray
Wolfe described the founding fathers as
obsessed with with manure so George
George Washington had this whoops keep
hitting this instead of the had this
building built to arm for the storing
of compost from dunk for his gardens so
agriculture places one in direct contact
with nature it teaches us the laws of
nature you're forced to experience it
firsthand you have to adapt your life to
the way things are there is a cycle to
it that we need to learn it's just the
way it is so some some history it's
agriculture is all in its totally
involved in our culture from the soil
health book I read that in ancient
writings such as the Bible the work in
the book of Genesis the word Adam means
red soil and that's reason is in this
just in this description human beings
became came from the soil because soil
brought forth life some Native American
Indian cultures treat the soil is a
living good neighbor they respect and
revere it and they talk about should
walk on the soil like you're walking on
somebody's back you know you need to be
very gentle with it in one culture
people take water from a well they first
pour a portion of the water onto the
ground to give the soil a drink first
that's how much they respect and revered
the soil in many of today's developing
countries people view using too much
fertilizer as we may view taking illegal
drugs they see it as making the soil
addicted so they like to keep things in
a natural way and that's why I think
it's good to support organic farming we
are converting one of our fields to an
organic farm and I know personally how
hard it is to pick up all those rocks it
is not easy
so things about agriculture how many of
us put off studying for an exam or cram
the night before we all did it right so
and it's something that's but this
approach doesn't work in agriculture you
can't procrastinate you know how many of
us know a farmer that can put off
milking your cows until Friday or the
night before a test before he wants to
do the milking you can't do that
can we cram our Faulk can we cram in the
fall for a crop harvest no we have to
plant in the spring in the spring in the
summer you begin harvesting wood for the
winter when the weather is right or or
you have five consecutive days of Sun
and the hay is tall enough to harvest
that's time you harvest hay
so your life is basically controlled by
your climate and by your weather you
can't have it the way always the way you
want it and you learned that very
quickly so some goat stories the only
good thing about having these goats it
gave me lots of good material we've had
a couple of goats we well first of all
my son had problems with the tolerance
to milk so I told my neighbor about
maybe we'll try looking at getting some
goats too because I hear that was better
for milk and tolerance two weeks late or
two goats showed up and I've never
touched a goat before okay they were
pregnant and they needed to be milked so
I had to quickly learn with them a
couple it within hours out of milk a
goat we had no place to store him but
anyway so what experience to experience
as I had with them was the two of the
babies were born and they needed they
couldn't milk off to the mother so I had
to battle feed them so I was getting
down to ten degrees one night so I took
him up and up the bathroom off of our
bathroom off of our bedroom went down to
get the milk and came up and it got out
of the bathroom they were standing next
to the bed as soon as I seen me open the
door and come in they jumped on the bed
and started peeing so anyway so
fortunately the plastic shipping
container was still on the mattress all
the bedding was up against the headboard
against the wall and the only nailed the
sheet but the worst part was when they
see me rush over to get them they
squatted down you could see him trying
to squeeze it all out before I got there
now they're only two weeks old
that's how mischievous goats are
then when I was building that Hut there
that I would I had it laid down on the
ground I was cutting it to length as
soon as I went to pick it up they all
jumped on it they have this immense
sense the knowing what's the worst thing
they could do at that moment okay so
questions some of our experiences the
reality of goats they looked so cute and
innocent don't they right they start out
so small I get but so what I learned
from them is how do you name a goat so I
learned from personal experiences the
first two names of all goats is exactly
the same you name a goat you give it its
third name so in this case this is that
damn brown ears okay so the first two
name for dos is that dam and then you
put the name onto it so one thing I
learned also about farming is just as
our culture is you know a church I know
I understand in the Bible why Jesus put
the sheep on his right and the goats on
his left
okay so there's just a lot of things
about agriculture that you really learn
firsthand the experience okay so tell
you a couple stories about my daughter
she was she was adopted she's she's 11
now she's going into fifth grade but
this year I think we she was in
kindergarten and she was a little bit
autistic so she couldn't speak to she
was about second year through
kindergarten and so the therapist told
us we had to keep the animals because I
know so she was with them she would
speak more and so we had to keep him for
therapy for her so we wanted to think of
getting rid of him we wondering how much
was it going to cost to keep him we
weighed that against what she was
learning and we decided to keep him and
so when she was forced the first thing
she didn't she had the chickens she
decided that before they could all go
out free-ranging they all had to pass
their flying test and she gave them all
flying lessons to him up in the air let
him come down anyway so then she got her
cutter friends how to give chickens
flying lessons that was hilarious
so we're wondering what is she what is
she learning and so she's watching the
little bill show and little bill Scott
there's a bunny rabbits from school that
he wants to adopt into his apartment in
Philadelphia his father tells him no and
he lists all the reasons
well mr. bills are a little bill had
already thought that problems out and
he's got a solution for every one of
them
now his father's got no recourse left
but to consider letting him have these
let him have these five rabbit or eight
rabbits Ellis ceased that happen on the
TV she looks up at the earth television
to give mr. bill some advice and she
says no no no those rabbits will poop a
lot and so by the age of five she has
waste management and scaled down I told
this to my neighbor I said she's really
learning a lot from being on the farm he
says yes she already knows she has now
already by the age of five has more
insight than half of the faculty in the
College of Agriculture okay so one last
story she's now in first grade at South
Hill and she's getting always gets books
on nature cuz she wants to be a
naturalist and she loves the woods and
she loves the animals and so this little
this book in this book this girl gets a
baby goat for a birthday it turns out
that every day it would go into it's hot
in the wintertime it would snow so after
several times this happening the gopis
in the hut it snows the girl thing she's
got a goat that can forecast the weather
so the next time it goes into its Hut
she calls up all this radio stations in
the news companies and they come down
and it didn't snow she's devastated so
she goes into the heart to see why the
goat was in there and it didn't snow
well it turned out the goat had given
birth to two baby kids and that's why it
had to go into the hot without it
snowing well I didn't catch on quick
enough my daughter turns to that front
page sizes up the horns on that coat
that goat there was no access to a billy
goat on the farm there's no way that
goat could have gotten pregnant
dad author then had no credibility right
she turns over to one of the previous
pages looks at the picture of the farm
animals in the corner and says dad that
Mouse doesn't belong there either so so
it's part of our culture we really kids
learn a lot okay
agriculture is a source of routine
micronutrient malnutrition affect over 2
billion people resulting in poor health
including coronary heart disease and so
these are all the important reasons for
agriculture agriculture just more than
the source of food nutrition we have the
old soil management and research in
agriculture but I found I was greatly
affected by climate change
so farming has taught me the importance
of keeping a system in balance
whenever I failed to comply with the
laws of nature and the system went out
of balance it didn't end well for me
agricultural policy needs to needs
accommodation both theory and practice
and I'm very appreciative for my
education at Cornell and so forth but I
also learned that a good education helps
prevent us from being deceived by
ignorance and some sense of spirituality
and understanding of the laws of nature
and complying with them can help us from
being deceived by her intellect and when
we're always surrounded by education I
think there's a tendency for us in
academic institutions to think that our
intellect is infallible and the first
thing I learned on a farm when I got the
farm was my neighborhoods a farmer knew
a lot more than I did so I had a lot of
theoretical practices but I needed some
common sense to go with it so
agriculture and climate change so I can
explore the connections so my my
expertise in chemistry that perspective
and how I understand climate change
based as a spectroscopy this is in the
at least in this ethic in New York your
life expectancy is much longer claiming
to be the Son of God than it is if you
come up or even propose the
possibilities that climate change may be
due to natural causes okay so what I'm
going to tell you why as a spectroscopy
so I think that it may be the case
there's science of the founding fathers
this belief that experience meant that
nature was the highest authority over
ruling and between any human authority
this point of view was encapsulated in
the model from the Royal Society to
premier scientific xiety in the world
nullus in verba in other words in on the
words of no one so in other words check
it out for yourself so I think some of
the evidence of this and like exciting
it was important to check out for myself
and I have a pretty good background in
chemistry and in some in physical
chemistry so I started looking into this
more deeply because how we approach
climate change tells us how what
adaptive methods we need to employ in
use if we use the wrong ones it could
end bad so here's the the mechanism for
climate change basically you have energy
coming into the earth some of it leaving
up into the atmosphere and then some of
it coming back down and this back
radiation they say is about 340 watts
per meter squared and so with the net
what's going out is 239 and so there's
basically we're accumulating a little
more energy than what's going out but
what's the mechanism for it so global
warming and climate change are both real
and serious issues that we need to
address I experienced them firsthand but
we need to be careful that we don't get
blindsided by causes other than co2 we
need to get the mechanism of greenhouse
effect correct so the current model
confuses the word thermal equilibrium
with steady state that would that's
their first mistake the second is
take is it only recognizes kerckhoffs
law and ignores the effect of thermal
collisions
I'll explain these independent later
coughs law has got some flaws in it to
begin with we need to recognize that
spectral displays that you see come off
an instrument are distorted and can lead
to erroneous conclusion so all these
things need to be taken into effect when
the circumstances are taken into
consideration it is possible that the
amount of atmosphere needed to create
the greenhouse effect would be reduced
from 12 to 16,000 feet down to about 350
feet resulting in thousands of feet of
extra asthma sphere not used to warm the
atmosphere so some of the limiting
factor controlling building warming may
not be co2 but sunlight so what the
spectroscopy evidence suggests is that
if this is 16,000 feet and there's an
that is required and there's still
radiation getting up to that height then
adding more co2 to the atmosphere would
increase global warming so human
activity would have an effect however if
the amount of co2 in the app if there's
enough co2 in the atmosphere at 350 feet
to absorb all the radiation that's
coming off the surface of the earth
that's that infrared radiation then all
of this from from here up to the outer
space is now extra and so adding more to
the natural extra that's already there
is not going to change the outcome or
very little change into the outcome so
to begin with based some basic physical
chemistry there there are four types of
kinetic energy
translation lens uses thermal heat row
tenant rotational energy which we know
as microwave energy vibrational energy
which is infrared electromagnetic
radiation which is the lights that you
see that's when electrons from an
excited state go back to a ground state
so the Maxwell Boltzmann equation for
thermal equilibrium predicts the ratio
of excited state of the electrons both
vibrational rotational
to the ground state is a function of
temperature so right here that's in
degrees Kelvin so this is your ground
state this is your excited state so it
says that when when energy we're not
when there's excitation of co2 the this
is going to get excited more as you get
increased temperature and this predicts
how much it will be excited so it's all
based on excitation of of your element
of your compound of interest by
temperature and so when you have
radiation coming from the surface of the
earth plus temperature imposing on co2
then the NB over na becomes
overpopulated the amount of excited co2
is now greater than what is predicted by
this equation that's why they should use
the term steady state and not thermal
equilibrium I think this is the place
mention it's probably the most abused
equation in science because nobody
really understands they use it without
totally understanding what it means so
the global more modeling is based on the
assumption that the Earth's surface and
the atmosphere being in thermal
equilibrium this is not the case because
the equation holds to if the source of
energy is thermal in the case of global
warming we are dealing with both
radiational energy and thermal energy
also these energies are in constant
state of flux so the system is at steady
state and at thermal equilibrium so for
for the excited state of co2 at the 4
micron peak it's about 0.03 percent at
the 15 micron peak it's about 2 percent
if you plug about 300 degrees Kelvin or
270 degrees Kelvin in that is for
temperature so when Co tubes absorbs
infrared radiation from the surface of
the earth the excited state becomes
overpopulating keeping it from being in
thermal equilibrium
the mechanism for global warming is
based on kirchoff's law and that is a
good absorber of radiation it's also a
good emitter of radiation and for the
most part that's generally true but in
infrared radiation IR radiation rating
from the surface of the earth is
observed by co2 the co2 then becomes
excited and then it releases the
infrared radiation in all directions the
earth absorbs some of the Rays
converting it
converting it to back to or back to
blackbody radiation then warming of the
air happens through convection so
essentially the radiation is coming up
from the earth it hits the co2 the co2
absorbs that radiation from one
direction but it releases it in all
directions because the ground absorbs
that radiation there's a net direction
down towards the earth so there's less
of it going up the atmosphere more of
it's coming down to the earth and that's
where they get that forcing mechanism
and the what they call the greenhouse
effect but there's some problems with
that what they didn't take into account
is the fact that nitrogen and oxygen are
combining are colliding with that
excited co2 in a rate of about three
billion times a second so at that point
instead of just the radiation warming to
ground it directly warms the air around
it so under those conditions instead of
needing a lot of atmosphere to direct
the light back down to the earth you
only need you need a much smaller volume
of atmosphere making more accessible and
excess so what they say is that when you
look at this spectrum here there's a
serious problem here does anybody know
what it is the tops of these things are
all flat nobody know why that is it's
basically because the radiation from the
ground isn't getting to outer space it's
all absorbed the other thing you notice
is the water makes up about 98 percent
of the greenhouse gases so all the
shaded areas here
is energy that's being absorbed and
prevented in warming the earth all the
white areas here is the emission and
going back to outer space cooling the
earth and what makes it was the warmer
cold is how these things are kept in
balance so if this is already saturated
adding more how much is that going to
affect global what is equity increase
global warming by adding more co2 when
it's already saturated and that depends
on the altitude that all this takes
place at and that's the one thing that
we don't have a direct measure of okay
so this is a paper by hung and Barrett
versus IPC IPCC and here's what it shows
some very interesting results so you see
this first curve here this is co2 alone
in an ampule in a vial or to that and it
absorbs this much radiation when you add
helium to it absorbs more radiation when
you add nitrogen to it the radiation
that absorbs is three times more so that
means that when co2 is colliding with
nitrogen and oxygen it's making more co2
atoms or molecules available for
absorption increasing its efficiency as
a greenhouse gas being again you need
less atmosphere than what's predicted if
you only look at the Kirkhof mechanism
so the IBC claims that the doubling of
co2 concentration would widen the
absorption spectra for co2 and that's
this area between the pink and the black
line that I put in okay so the spectra
comes down and it winds out at the
bottom and what they're saying is that
well if you double the co2 then this
white area where the light or the
radiation state to outer space who gets
smaller because this would start to fill
in with the co2 absorption and I I don't
think that's going to happen and from a
spectroscopy of view
we know that these images have
distortions in them and so you can't
directly until you have to realize that
this absorption peak is actually wider
than what's displayed so there's a lot
of distortions and these spectrometers
and you need to be aware of that when
you do your calculations so what they're
saying is that the IPCC is saying that
for point this would account for an
additional 4.3 watts per meter square of
energy coming back to the earth I'm
saying that's probably not going to
happen and explain why so here's I'm
sorry about this slide I'm not very good
at PowerPoint but if you were to have a
perfect spectrometer that was going to
image exactly the radiation pattern that
is entering it but you would have would
be the straight blue green and red lines
with nothing in the middle okay but when
the light enters into a spectrometer it
gets distorted because of the grating
the width of the entrance slit the width
of the exit slit D the lenses
whatever's used to image the light or
the energy coming in it ends up being
distorted so it shifts it to the left
and to the right so you see this line
here this is it let's say this green
light is 500 nanometers so the emission
coming at 495 is not a wavelength of 495
it's a wavelength of 500 that has been
displayed at 495 so that means you when
you look at the spectra the only part
that's accurate part of the spectrum is
what's exactly in the center and what's
on the edges is distortions and you need
to keep that in mind when you're making
your interpretation so here's what
happened
it's sort of like this here's me
throwing a basketball and you notice
that when you take a picture of it
because you can't have an an instant
image it gets distorted okay
here's a close-up of it okay this same
effect is the same thing that happens
inside a spectrometer so you've got to
know about understand this when you do
calculate when you run calculations so
those obviously claims that this
doubling would be 4.3 and I'm saying the
reason this peak is is narrowing is not
matching the black line is because the
radiation in the white areas is spilling
over into it preventing it from being as
wide as it really would be displayed if
we had a perfect spectrometer and so
solis so the doctor hines hyung did an
experiment he looked at he used a
high-res instrument and his conclusions
was that the amount of additional
radiation coming back to the earth if
you doubled co2 would be this small
edges here in here and that the forcing
would be only 0.05 4 watts per meter
squared rather than the 4 point 3 that's
predicted by the IPCC ok so the global
warming is going to be a lot less but if
you increase co2 in the atmosphere I had
trouble finding any place that explained
exactly how they do the calculations so
I found this paper by the American
Chemical Society that gave it a temp
explaining it and what bothered me was
the fact that it says this figure
simulates what would happen if you had
an imaginary atmosphere so I'm not sure
how did they do their measurements that
they just take direct measurements or
did they just do a simulation to come up
with these numbers that they're using
for
what's going to happen if we increase
co2 in our atmosphere how much is
attempt you're going to change I'm not
comforting
if people are just doing simulations
rather than direct measurements you're
saying that the red line is wider than
the blue line based on a simulation I
don't know so I don't think there is
enough evidence to come to a definitive
conclusion the material presented here
needs to be taken given serious
consideration and not we just accept the
dogma that's out there to resolve this
issue we need a direct measure and not a
model for the amount of atmosphere
needed to create the greenhouse effect
you know how much of the atmosphere is
extra this is important because we need
to know which adaptive strategies and
policies we need to implement that's
really critical for agriculture the
experiment we need to perform
we need neo to the concentration of co2
at different locations around the earth
what is the amount of co2 in the
atmosphere the limiting factor or is
radiation from the Sun limiting if we
add more co2 the atmosphere will it add
to the greenhouse effect depends on the
altitude you have to go before all the
radiation from the earth is absorbed
we need an experiment that measures the
radiation from the earth that is
observed by co2 at different elevations
and the Earth's atmosphere one of the
technical problems with infrared
radiation and measuring it is that the
infrared radiation also comes from the
instrument itself and from the detector
so the detector is measuring its own
radiation so technically you need to get
the instrument chilled to like a minus
40 degrees so that when you're when
you're doing your experiment the
filament is about the same temperature
as the surface of the earth and 15
degrees you don't kill the instrument
then you can't see a difference okay so
so this is some beers law and it talks
about how anything is absorbed how it
goes straight and then it begins to tell
off so if co2 absorbs goes about to 95%
of CC at 12,000 feet adding more
anthropologic co2 would cause global
warming because this will continue up
very slowly okay and so if you've got if
it takes all 12,000 to 16,000 feet
adding more co2 by us would make an
effect if co2 absorption falls off at
about 1350 feet more co2 won't really
matter it would all be extra and it
would be like having a sponge pick up
one teaspoon water adding 10 sponges
isn't going to pick up any more water
because you've already you already
absorbed all of it but almost all of it
so here's my experiment now let's see if
this works okay you block out the what
was the so it starts off with a laser
which is the source of radiation so you
replace that with a with a light tube
turn it upside down face it towards the
earth you put it into a minus 40 degree
box of somebody's that didn't turn
around but anyways so we have to turn
the helicopter around I guess so anyway
so now name it down then you come in
with helicopter comes in and now fly off
so I think this is experiment we need to
do so we know exactly where that
absorption takes place that this was in
case the previous slide didn't work okay
so let's say we put need to know here
and here and at what point does the
absorption go to nearly nearly to zero
that's a really critical measurement
that we don't have that goes up
okay so I just want to give you some
perspective of the historical record
that we have so here we have high levels
of co2 gradually coming down then we
have the temperature of the earth so
here the oceans froze over warmed up and
right now we're over here okay so we so
we are still in the Ice Age now this is
the same thing but it's on a log scale
so it amplifies the recent history so
you can see recently we've had climate
change going on for a long time now it's
trending up but look what the trends
have been before
I mean climate change is something
that's been going on for millions of
years and there's I don't think there's
any reason to expect that this is always
going to be the new norm or what we're
experiencing today so climate change
gives us a real challenge for growing
more food because it makes it harder it
does make it harder to grow food so this
is why I think adaptation becomes so
important that's why I'm so enthusiastic
about the soil health program because if
you don't take good care of the soil you
lose it you're not going to be able to
grow crops when you have issues with
climate change you have too much water
or too little it's going to be hard to
grow food so here's a no-till farm it's
much better practice it absorbs water
through the soil it stores water in the
groundwater the soil doesn't run off and
you can grow more food we need to use
molecular biology to grow aluminum
tolerant plants that can withstand
weathering in various conditions so we
can grow food in more arid lands we need
to use green house operations the
tomatoes from back there came from this
green and from our greenhouse operation
but I learned in using a controlled
environment and agriculture you can
actually go very good tasting tomatoes
because I don't because I can isolate it
from the environment I can control
disease without using pesticides or
fungicides or herbicides or any
chemicals you start them in January and
they outgrow the disease and so I don't
need to grow the genetically modified
tapeless tomatoes but I can actually
grow good tasting ones and sell them
locally so I think this needs to be more
advanced so here's my daughter and a
friend they're planting seeds and pots
in the greenhouse um I want see if this
will play back this is kind of nice and
what a farmer is so misses the end of
the slide and I hope this is the future
generation of Agriculture so take any
questions anybody has questions yeah
that because they have the temperature
in the co2 concentration exact same time
so they don't where the window is yeah
and they know how the co2 concentration
is changing and then we also need to
know what it is over the oceans we need
to know what it's over land right what
altitude does their atmosphere absorb
all that infrared radiation I mean
that's the real crux of the whole
problem and I think on was it
of hemingway from where it said there's
lies dental eyes and their statistics
and maybe we should then extend that to
computer modeling you know if you don't
have the numbers right you don't
understand your system then it becomes
hard to give an accurate prediction and
the other questions yeah you know I
think we have to revise a little bit
your story of the American Declaration
of Independence George Washington may
have been a farmer but how many slaves
did you guys have actually telling how
much was he himself killing we all know
about Jefferson he you know this
idealism in John Adams were sitting up
there boss he was a lawyer so I don't
quite get that and then the Declaration
of Independence was primarily as we now
know about because Britain was about to
abolish slavery because the king was
dealing with the Indians fairly Native
Americans fairly and because he left the
Quebecers keep their Catholic religion
if you read in the Declaration of
Independence the list of grievances
against the king you're going to see
this part you put with just window
dressing up so I think we thanks for
bringing that up one day or one before
we want like that but it
where's the window with the earth is
raining so there's this rating in all
the areas that are in white what that's
the blackbody radiation okay so so this
is inverted because this is looking at
right where would he you can't do that
here because I don't get the blackbody
missions from right so temperature yes
so where would that be a Medina is that
important to keep radiation from the
earth yes it's not on this tag this is
an absorption spectra and this is we're
also with the water sets and you also
have another fart and I believe this is
at atmospheric pressure throughout the
atmosphere so it's gonna be low pressure
to high pressure well some of its going
to be surfaced some of its also going to
be a result up in the upper atmosphere
yeah it's perfect in away from the
surface
well the question becomes the sips does
the co2 radiation does the radiation
from
earth that's that co2 can't capture does
it get that high to begin with that's
the important question is right at the
center point almost to right water vapor
window you do not create the other one
thing that is enlightening is actually
not a major emission temperature or a
radius near surface so I think the
launching over those details you know I
don't have the the slide to I put in
here it still money so I didn't have the
slide because the peak around 44 microns
is really irrelevant it doesn't matter
if it there's not that much heat coming
there's not much out killing for that
that's like what they saw the radiation
and the radiation so the only really
weird saturating not yeah but still
actually methane which is over there is
irrelevant to what one thing keep in
mind that the energy at this end of the
spectrum is much greater than the energy
at this end of the spectrum it's a very
outdated a lot of court system trying to
gather funds even here I'm basically
limited plankton being able back to the
Camry yeah it's true that there are coal
plants and past and that major did that
occurs right at the end of the art
addition is well known and
so the harmonization these are
well-known events to have correlated
especially that second one to go back to
the enemy earning at the end of the
Carboniferous so 300 years Carboniferous
the term differs is named for them that
God asked you to provide us with a plant
which is linked to white spread
radiation which actually supports the
hypothesis the strong correlation
technique co2 and climate for time they
totally agreed unless have movie years
we've been in nightlife climate on
average but the numbers in terms of
actual temperature increased or talking
about during the period of dinosaurs is
I mean very dramatic right correlate to
the co2 even had a huge yes it would I
don't yeah but it matters it co2 because
yeah there's something that we can do
about but then it all comes down this
one basic answer is we don't have how
much of it in the atmosphere do we need
that's causing the climate change is it
this much or is it this much that's the
critical spectroscopic answer that we
have to have made right that's what it's
not supported by the for ponder the net
is that come from different types of
modeling observation but how did they
arrive at those watts per meter squared
did they use the wrong assumptions from
the spectroscopy curves that's the
question I'm bringing up you can get a
similar reconstruction of global
temperatures going back 700 you show the
curve Yoga doesn't well you use that
time series whatever temperature into
volcanic eruptions you get a sensitivity
the radiative term to of about saying
you know frequent flyers one seven well
he knows but he still radiative forcing
yeah either from the models like
excitement or it could be from the
climate Emmett excuse you put you into
that same baller you can do it from a
simple energy balance law so there's
there's multiple avenues to give us this
to afford a free estimate and those are
well know and to tipple also over that i
think this is not an accurate portrayal
in science data science because would
you like to do some board and your
vision for the for some constant which
one we're seeing articles here that
people are welcome to read I have copies
of them they want to go through some
look at it from both sides
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu